>> Tucker: JOE BIDEN NOMINATED
DAVID CHIPMAN TO LEAD THE ATF.
THIS IS A CONCERN FOR A NUMBER
OF REASONS.
FIRST DAVID IS SUCH A ZEALOT HE
HAS SHOWN HIMSELF TO BE WILLING
TO LIE IN THE SERVICE OF HIS
IDEALOGY.
HE CLAIMED THE BRANCH DAVIDIANS
IN WACO SHOT DOWN FEDERAL
HELICOPTERS.
THAT WAS NOT TRUE AND HE KNEW
THAT.
TODAY HE AGAIN FAILED TO TELL
THE TRUTH.
HE SAID GUN OWNERS OF AR- 15'S
SHOULD BE ARRESTED.
>> I SUPPORT A BAN AS HAS BEEN
PRESENTED IN A SENATE BILL AND
SUPPORTED BY THE PRESIDENT.
THE AR-15 IS A LETHAL WEAPON AND
REGULATING IT HAS OTHER
PARTICULARLY LETHAL WEAPONS I
ADVOCATE FOR, I WOULD ENFORCE
THE LAWS
ON THE B.
>> Tucker: THAT'S FALSE.
YOU WOULD NOT TAKE IT DEER HUNT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT LEGAL ENOUGH.
WE WANT TO SPEAK TO JESSE KELLY
TONIGHT.HUNTING BECAUSE IT'S NO
ENOUGH.
WE WANT TO SPEAK TO JESSE KELLY
TONIGHT.
THERE ARE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
AR15S IN CIRCULATION.
WHAT WOULD IS MEAN TO BAN THEM?
>> WE WOULD GET THE WORLD THAT
DAVID WANTS TO HURT ANYBODY WHO
DISAGREES WITH HIM.
THIS IS THE MISTAKE WE MAKE ON
THE RIGHT.
WE HEAR OF THIS BAN AND WE SAY
PISTOLS HURT MORE PEOPLE EVERY
YEAR.
DAVID IS AN IDIOT BUT HE CAN
READ.
HE WANTS THE FREEDOM TO HURT
YOU.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE HAVE TO
DANCE AROUND THAT.
>> Tucker: WHY DOES NOBODY SAY
THAT?
>> WELL, BECAUSE IT MEANS
ACKNOWLEDGING YOUR FELLOW
AMERICANS WANT YOU DEAD OR ARE
OKAY IF YOU ARE DEAD.
THEY CALLED YOU A NAZI FOR 4
YEARS FOR A REASON.
DO YOU THINK DAVID CHIPMAN
THINKS NAZIS SHOULD OWN AR-15S.
HE WANTS THE AUTHORITY TO BAN
THEM.
PUTTING HIM IN CHARGE OF THE ATF
IS LIKE THROWING A PARTY FOR
FRIENDS AND LETTING BILL COSBY
TEND THE BAR.
>> Tucker: YOU TARGET A FIRE ARM
OWNED BY LAW ABIING PEOPLE WHO
COMMIT NO CRIMES.
TO TARGET THEM TELLS YOU IT'S
NOT ABOUT REDUCING VIOLENCE, IS
IT?
>> OH, NO, IT'S NOT ABOUT
REDUCING REAL VIOLENCE.
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE CARE ABOUT
MASS SHOOTINGS OR INNER CITY
VIOLENCE.
THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THEIR FINAL SOCIALIST
DREAM IN AMERICA BECAUSE HALF OF
THE COUNTRY OWNS A LOT OF
FIREARMS.
IT'S THE ONLY THING SEPARATING